ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. HI WE ARE CURRY.
ARAMBULA BARRICADE HAND IT
BERMAN BIGELOWLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BURKE
CALDERON RIO CERVANTES CHAU.
TEN TO CHOI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY DAVIES
FLORA PHONE FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEAD.
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA WHEN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORK CORK SILVA
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE
TEAM VALLADARES BE APPROVED BY
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. THE DAYS PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR KHAN THE
MONEY'S THERE. IN THE NAME OF
GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL ALMIGHTY GOD. GIVEN
EACH OF US THE OPPORTUNITY
ENCOURAGED TO REACH WITHIN
OURSELVES. SO THAT AS WE STRIVE
TO ACHIEVE OUR HIGHEST
POTENTIAL. OUR ENTIRE SOCIETY
WILL BE BLESSED AS WELL MAY
THIS BE GOD'S WELL. I MEAN.
THANK YOUR MIND YES THERE WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AS HE
LEADS THIS MONTH BUT-
COLLEAGUES JOINS ME PLEDGE. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE. COOL
LAW THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
MOVING TO THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
SALMON SACRAMENTO TUESDAY
JANUARY TWENTY SIX TWENTY
TWENTY. MISTER KALRA SECONDS AT
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
IDENTIFICATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS ARE ABSENCES FOR
DATE TODAY FOR PERSONAL
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MCCARTY AND KILEY. FOR ILLNESS
IN THE FAMILY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
GONZALEZ IN WAX AND FOR MEDICAL
LEAVE AS FAMILY MEMBERS FRAZIER
WORK IN BIGELOW. MEMBERS I ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE KEEP YOUR
VOICES TO A MINIMUM AND
MAINTAIN THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS OF THE FLOOR THANK
YOU. ISRAEL'S YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MISSION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FOR FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MULLIN. THE
WHAT THE GARCIA CERVANTES AND
RUBIO TO SPEAK ON A JOURNEY IN
MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. MISTER
WELL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR INTRODUCTION OF LUNAR NEW
YEAR AT THE FRONT OF THE
CHAMBER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES.
HAPPY LUNAR NEW YEAR OF THE OX
IF I COULD KINDLY YEAH I GET
YOUR ATTENTION AS OUR ON BEHALF
OF THE API LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS
WE'VE LEFT YOU. WITH A- SMALL
GIFT OF RECOGNITION FOR A
PROSPEROUS LUNAR NEW YEAR. TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE LUNAR NEW
YEAR OF THE OX. BUT ALSO AN
OPPORTUNITY OF A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION MADAM SPEAKER.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THANK YOU.
OUR ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY WISHES YOU A
PROSPEROUS LUNAR NEW YEAR. WE
ARE EVERYWHERE PART OF THE
FABRIC OF SOCIETY. WE ARE YOUR
DOCTORS. WE ARE YOUR NURSES.
THANK YOU OF IN CS ROAMING THE
HALLS OF THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
WE'VE BEEN WILL FEED YOU ON
CHRISTMAS WHEN NO ONE ELSE WILL.
BUT AT SAME TIME COLLEAGUES.
THERE IS THE RISE OF THE YELLOW
PERIL. YOU HEARD ABOUT THE
NOTION ABOUT THE COMMON FLU
OTHER WUHAN VIRUS MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY BEING ACCUSED AS
CHINESE SPIES WHEN MANY OF THEM
AREN'T EVEN CHINESE. ACCORDING
TO STOP áP I HATE. AN
ORGANIZATION CATEGORIZING THE
INCREASE IN HATE CRIMES
CALIFORNIA ALONE HAS SEEN 43%
INCREASE IN HATE CRIMES TOWARDS
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY. AS ALL OF YOU KNOW.
INVASION PATHFINDER CULTURE
RESPECTS OVER ELDERS AS A HIGH
VALUE. AND YES. WE'RE SEEING
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY BEING
HARASSED. MURDERED ON EVERY DAY
STREETS IN THE UNITED STATES
AND HERE YES IN EVEN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. A NINETY
ONE YEAR OLD WAS ASSAULTED IN
OAKLAND CHINATOWN. AN EIGHTY
YEAR OLD IN PASADENA MURDERED
JUST SIMPLY CROSSING THE STREET.
AN EIGHTY FOUR YEAR OLD. OF
THAI DESCENT WAS ASSAULTED AND
SUBSEQUENTLY DIED FROM HIS
INJURIES IN FACT THE THAI
CONSULATE HAS EVEN ISSUED A
WARNING TO THAIS LIVING IN THE
UNITED STATES IN CALIFORNIA TO
BE AWARE. A SUCH HATE CRIMES.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT THERE ARE
MANY IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT.
THINK ABOUT THIS AS A QUESTION
OF OUR EXPERIENCE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. AND WE HEAR. WHY IS
IT THAT ARE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITY FIGHTS FOR
EVERYONE. BUT NO ONE FIGHTS
ROSS. OUR LUNAR NEW YEAR IS
ABOUT A CELEBRATION OF FOOD AND
OF CULTURE. BUT THERE'S SO MUCH
MORE TO IT. WE ASK FOR YOUR
SOLIDARITY. A COLLEAGUES YOU'LL
BE SEEING A RESOLUTION THIS
COMING TUESDAY AND WHICH OTHERS
WILL BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN
SOLIDARITY BUT I ASK YOU I
PLEAD WITH YOU. STAND UP WITH
US. ARE YOU OKAY CAUCUS ASKED
YOU TO STAND UP WITH US STAND
UP IN SOLIDARITY TO SPEAK OUT
AGAINST THESE HATE CRIMES TO CS
LITERALLY STAND UP SO YOU CAN
SEE US. HERE US. ISSUE
STATEMENTS AGAINST AGE PROVIDER
HATE CRIMES. ASK YOUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHAT YOU CAN BE DOING
TO ADDRESS THIS SENSELESS
VIOLENCE. AND AGAIN AS YOU
STAND UP WITH US TO RECOGNIZE
LUNAR NEW YEAR. LET US WELCOME.
A PROSPEROUS TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE YEAR OF THE OX
BECAUSE GOD DANG IT WE KNOW
THIS YEAR'S GONNA BE BETTER
THAN THE LAST THANK YOU FOR
CALLING. THANK YOU MR LOW.
RECOGNIZING THE LUNAR NEW YEAR
AND MADE THE BLESSING OF ALL OF
THOSE LIVES LOST TO HATE CRIMES
THE A BLESSING IS FOR THIS BODY
TO ACTION. LIVING TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE. FILE ITEMS
ONE AND TWO WILL BE PASSED IN.
THIRTEEN MEMBERS WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADORNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR. THE. THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS ARE GRANTED PERMISSION
TO SPEAK ON IN A GERMAN MEMORY.
MR GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY. IN
THE REAR CHAMBER. MEMBERS YOUR
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION PLEASE
THANK THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
INFORM YOU THAT ON TUESDAY
JANUARY NINETEENTH. THE FIFTY
SIX ONLY DISTRICT LOSS ONE OF
ITS PEERS APPLICANTS- KEVENEY
CALLIE. RIGHT BEFORE YOU TODAY
TO ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY.
KEVIN KELLY WAS A PROUD IMPAIR
VALLEY NATIVE WHO HAD LONG
SINCE A SUCCESSFUL CAREER AS A
JOURNALIST WRITER. POLITICAL
CONSULTANT EXECUTIVE AND
MUSICIAN. HAVING GRADUATED FROM
BRAWLEY UNION HIGH SCHOOL AND
ATTENDED THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. IT WAS
DURING HIS COLLEGE DAYS AND
DECIDED TO PURSUE A CAREER IN
MUSIC. TAKE A BREAK FROM
COLLEGE TO. TRY AND MAKE A
LIVING AS A JAZZ PIANIST
PLAYING CLUBS IN LOS ANGELES
AND SAN DIEGO. ULTIMATELY
DECIDED TO RETURN TO SCHOOL.
HAVING GRADUATED FROM USC IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR WITH A
COMMUNICATIONS DEGREE AND MOVED
BACK HOME TO IMPAIR COUNTY. YET
USING REMAIN PART OF HIS LIFE
PLAYING WITH LOCAL GROUPS AND
BANDS WHEN EVERY GOOD. HE
CONTINUED. TO PERSON WHAT WAS
HIS PASSION. AND THAT WAS TO
SERVE IN HIS COMMUNITY HIS
PROFESSIONAL CAREER TOOK HIM.
TO WORK FOR THE EL CENTRO
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. CO
FOUNDING THE VALLEY GROWER
MAGAZINE SERVING AS- THE
OPINION PAGE EDITOR FOR THE
APPROVAL OF PRESS. HELPING
CANDIDATES RUN FOR LOCAL OFFICE
AND LEADING THE APPROPRIATION
DISTRICT AT ITS GENERAL
MANAGER. FROM TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN. THROUGH HIS RETIREMENT
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. KEVIN
LOVE THIS COMMUNITY AND
DEDICATED HIMSELF TO MAKING IT
A BETTER PLACE. HIS KNOWLEDGE
OF HISTORY OF THE IMPERIAL
VALLEY AND THE COLORADO RIVER
WAS UNPARALLELED. ISRAEL
REGULARLY HE REGULARLY TAKE ON
THE FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS. TO REMIND US ALL. OF
THE VALLEYS REGISTRY AND THE
CRITICAL ROLE IN WATER POLITICS
AGRICULTURE AND RENEWABLE
ENERGY PRODUCTION OUR EGION
HOLDS. TO THIS DAY. I HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING CLOSELY
WITH KEVIN. ONE OF THE MOST
CRITICAL ISSUES HE CHAMPION AS
GENERAL MANAGER OF THE
INTERROGATION DISTRICT. WAS AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE THE
RESTORATION THE SALTON SEA FOR
MANY OF US. HE REMINDED US OF
THE STATE LIABILITY THAT WE
TOOK ON WHEN WE FORCED UPON
IMPERIAL COUNTY ONE OF THE
LARGEST WATER TRANSFERS IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF ACRES
OF WATER THAT WAS TAKEN FROM A
BURKE COUNTY. TO GO TO SAN
DIEGO. AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE A
HUGE. LIABILITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY TO FIND
RESTORATION MITIGATION PROJECTS
AT THE SALTON SEA. AND WE WON'T
STOP THAT WORK. THAT KEVIN. WAS
A FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR. I HAD
THE PLEASURE TO HEAR HIM PLAY
THE PIANO. ON A FEW OCCASIONS.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT-
WITHOUT QUESTION HE HAD
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF TALENT.
THAT TO HE COULD FOLLOW THAT
PATH. BUT HE CHOSE TO GO BACK
HOME AND SERVE IMPERIAL COUNTY
COMMUNITIES. TODAY WE RECOGNIZE
THIS GENTLEMAN MR KEAVENEY
GALLEY AND EXTEND OUR MOST
HEARTFELT CONDOLENCES TO HIS
FAMILY AND FRIENDS DURING HIS
DIFFICULT TIME. OUR COMMUNITY
REMAINS FOREVER GRATEFUL FOR
HIS INCREDIBLE LEGACY
CONTRIBUTION CERTAINLY FOR IS
DOWNPLAYING MORE SOUL FOR HIS
FRIENDSHIP AND HIS PUBLIC
SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND THE
PEOPLE OF IMPERIAL COUNTY ASKED
WE ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY
TODAY. THANK YOU MR GARCIA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED YOUR SECOND
GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU MA'AM
SPEAKER TODAY. ITSELF WITH THE-
SADNESS THAT WE- HAVE THE RISE
IN HONOR THE LIFE OF
DISTINGUISHED SERVICE. OF A US
ARMY KOREAN WAR VETERAN WAS
SAID JIMMY PASTORAL. SHE PASSED
WITH A LIFELONG HOPE WILL
RESIDENTS. HE PASSED AWAY ON
JANUARY AT THE AGE OF NINETY
ONE. THE TO COMPLICATIONS FROM
COVER NINETEEN. AS A CHILD HERE
THE SIBLINGS WORKED IN LOCAL
IMPERIAL VALLEY. AGRICULTURAL
FIELDS AND IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY- LIKE MANY OF THE
STORIES OF THE FOLKS WHO SIT IN
THIS CHAMBER. JIMMY WAS DRAFTED
BY THE U. S. ARMY IN DECEMBER
OF NINETEEN FIFTEEN OF THIS
PLOY TO KOREA IN NINETEEN FIFTY
ONE. WITH THE US ARMY SEVEN
CALVARY. REGIMENT WELL I CAREER
CASTRO THE SQUAD LEADER AND WAS
WOUNDED MULTIPLE TIMES IN
OCTOBER FIRST NINETEEN FIFTY
ONE. HE SUSTAINED A GUNSHOT
WOUND IN HIS LEFT SHOULDER FOR
AN ENEMY'S RIFLE AND HOURS
LATER WAS INJURED BY SNORKEL
FROM THE MORNING. WHICH LEFT
HIM IMMOBILE ONE OF HIS CLOSE
FRIENDS CRAWL THROUGH GUNFIRE
TO RESCUE HIM. ONCE RESCUED
CASTRO WAS EVACUATED TO JAPAN
BY AIR AND SUBSEQUENTLY
RECEIVED A PURPLE HEART. FOR
HIS COMBAT RELATED INJURIES AND
MANY MANY OTHER STORIES I'VE
BEEN TOLD. ABOUT MR CASTRO AND
HIS TIME SERVING OUR GREAT
COUNTRY. CASTRO AND HIS SEVEN
BROTHERS- BULBUL CAPITAL'S
CANADA SOME OF WHOM YOU'LL SEE
YOU IN A LITTLE WHILE
RECOGNIZED BECAUSE THEY TOO
WERE ALL. MEMBERS OF THE ARMED
SERVICES FOR OUR COUNTRY- THIS.
SURVIVAL HIS LOVING WIFE LIVIA
THERE FOR CHILDREN. AND WE ARE
HONORED TO BE ABLE TO RETURN IN
HIS MEMORY AGAIN ANOTHER GREAT
LAWYER FOR OUR STATE WHO HAS
LOST HIS LIFE TO COVER NINETEEN
I ASKED TO RETURN. IN THIS-
VETERAN WITH A PURPLE HEART
RECIPIENT WAS A GERMAN CASTLES
ON. THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
GARCIA. MISTER MIND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO ASK. THAT THE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF THOMAS MORE WHO
PASSED AWAY. ON NOVEMBER FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY FIVE. WARNING CANTON
OHIO TOM MOORE ATTENDED ST
LOUIS UNIVERSITY BEGAN TEACHING
BEFORE EVENTUALLY MOVING WITH
HIS FAMILY TO CALIFORNIA IN
NINETEEN SIXTY TWO. HE JOINED
THE STAFF AT HIGH SCHOOL IN
PACIFICA THE YOUNG CHEMISTRY
TEACHER AND WAS RECOGNIZED FOR
TEACHING BY RECEIVING THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING CHEMISTS
ASSOCIATION AWARD. OVER THE
COURSE OF HIS DISTINGUISHED
CAREER TOM SERVICE AND
EXCEPTIONAL ADMINISTRATIVE
LEADER IN EDUCATION. INCLUDING
AS THE PRINCIPAL OF THREE SAN
MATEO COUNTY HIGH SCHOOLS
ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
SAN MATEO UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND SUPERINTENDENT OF
THE DISTRICT UNTIL HIS
RETIREMENT IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR. BEING AS HE WAS A
PASSIONATE LEADER AND HAVING A
KEEN AWARENESS OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES OF AFFORDABLE GATEWAYS
TO SUCCESS. TOM CAME OUT OF
RETIREMENT THEY WENT ON TO LEAD
KENYATTA COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS
ITS PRESIDENT FOR SIX YEARS HE
THEN WENT ON TO BECOME AN
ELECTED MEMBER OF THE SAN MATEO
COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
WELL KNOWN FOR GENEROUS
SPIRITED LEADERSHIP TOM MOORE
SERVED AS A MENTOR TO TEACHERS
AND EDUCATIONAL PROFESSIONALS
THROUGHOUT SAN MATEO COUNTY.
NEVER LOSING SIGHT OF THE NEED
TO PROTECT UNDERSERVED AND
MARGINALIZED PEOPLE THROUGHOUT
THE COMMUNITY TOM SERVED AS AN
ADVOCATE FOR EQUITY DIVERSITY
FAIRNESS. AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
AND EDUCATION HIS LEGACY IS A
TIRELESS EDUCATION ADVOCATE THE
LEADERS UNDOUBTEDLY LEFT A
LASTING MARK ONSAN MATEO
COUNTY'S EDUCATORS AND STUDENTS
AND HE WILL BE SORELY MISSED.
SIMPLY PUT HE WAS A GIANT OF
OUR COMMUNITY THOMAS SURVEYS
LOVING WIFE OF FORTY SIX YEARS
SAID HE HAS THREE CHILDREN MARK
LAUREN TOM AS WELL AS MANY
GRAND AND GREAT GRAND CHILDREN.
WITH THAT I ASKED THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY. OF TOM
MOORE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER MULLIN RESTAURANT AS YOU.
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM. AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE CHASSIS
ASSEMBLY TO JOURNEY IN MEMORY
OF ROBERT MARTINEZ OF CORONA.
ROBERT DEDICATED HIS LIFE TO
HELPING PEOPLE AND SAVING
PEOPLE'S LIVES HE GREW UP IN
BALDWIN PARK GRADUATING FROM
BALDWIN PARK HIGH SCHOOL IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE. AFTER
HIGH SCHOOL ROBERT ATTENDED AND
GRADUATED FROM THE DANIEL
FREEMAN. AT A PROGRAM AT UCLA
AND WORKED AS A PARAMEDIC FOR
TEN YEARS ONE OF THE HIGHLIGHTS
OF HIS SERVICE AS A PARAMEDIC
WAS BEING ASSIGNED TO THE U. S.
FENCING TEAM DURING THE
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR SUMMER
OLYMPICS IN LA. ROBERT THEN
CHANGE CAREERS AND BEGAN
WORKING IN RADIOLOGY AS A
CARDIO CATHETERIZATION LAB
TECHNOLOGIST FOR THE NEXT
THIRTY ONE YEARS. HE MADE A
LIVING SAVING LIVES. IN
NINETEEN NINETY HE MARRIED
FRANCES AND TOGETHER THEY HAD A
DAUGHTER NAMED SELENA. IN HIS
SPARE TIME HE ENJOYED DEEP SEA
FISHING AND OFTEN WENT TO
SEVERAL FISHING TRIPS IN ALASKA
WITH HIS CO WORKERS. ROBERT
PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF SIXTY
THREE ON JANUARY NINTH HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE FRANCES
DAUGHTERS SELENA HIS SISTER
MARY AND HIS BROTHER BROTHER
REUBEN. MEMBERS I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF
ROBERT MARTINEZ. THANK YOU MISS
CERVANTES MAYES RUBIO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SEAKER
AND MEMBERS IT IS WITH GREAT
SADNESS THAT I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF DR JOHN
WALLACE THE SIXTEENTH PRESIDENT
OF THIS IS A PACIFIC
UNIVERSITY. AS AN ALUMNI OF THE
UNIVERSITY I CANNOT EMPHASIZE
THE MASSIVE IMPACT THE DOCTOR
WALLACE HAD ON SO MANY YOUNG
MINDS. DR WALLACE CAME TO A P.
YOU AS AN UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO.
EARNING A BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND
AN MBA. HE EMBARKED ON HIS
PROFESSIONAL CAREER AT THE
UNIVERSITY UPON GRADUATION
HOLDING MANY POSITIONS ON
CAMPUS FROM CUSTODIAN TO DEAN
OF STUDENTS. ALL THE WAY TO
PRESIDENT. UNDER DOCTOR
WALLACE'S LEADERSHIP AB YOU
BECAME A NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
LEADER IN CHRISTIAN HIGHER
EDUCATION. COMMITTED TO MAKING
COLLEGE MORE ACCESSIBLE AND
AFFORDABLE FOR ITS STUDENTS
THIS FAITH AND LEARNING
COMMUNITY HAS SEEN ENROLLMENT
MORE THAN DOUBLED IN THE LAST
EIGHTEEN YEARS. DURING HIS
PRESIDENCY WALLACE HELPED USHER
IN A NEW ERA OF COUGAR
ATHLETICS WHEN AP YOU
OFFICIALLY JOINED THE NATIONAL
COLLEGIATE ATHLETIC ASSOCIATION
DIVISION TO. HE HAS SERVED ON
THE BOARDS OF THE ASSOCIATION
OF INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES AND
THE COUNCIL OF CHRISTIAN
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES. DR
WALLACE WILL DEEP WILL BE
DEEPLY MISSED IN THE AB YOU
COMMUNITY AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. THANK YOU MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY TODAY OF DR
JOHN WALLACE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THIS RUBIO MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAME SUGGESTS WE
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS MONDAY
FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH IS
PRESIDENT'S DAY. TUESDAY
FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH- HOPE FOR
SESSION AT ONE PM ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
RETAINED ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN
THIS RACE MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS AT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL TUESDAY
FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH. AT ONE PM.